Aoife, we are going to try and use your voice
to break this glass here, all right? So over
here, we have a microphone, OK? And to help
you with that note, we've got the same note
playing in these ear phones. So that should
be about the right note so that that note
corresponds with the natural frequency of
this glass. So it goes into resonance.
So you want to get the molecules of the glass
vibrating like sound energy in the voice of
Ifa here to show you just how destructive
sound can be. Now, Ifa, this is really hard
to do. I'll tell you now, I had to go. But
I'm a rubbish singer. So I'm expecting greatness
from you. OK. So, ready, steady, go.
Ah.
Oh, close. Cause, Aoife, good try. Good try.
[APPLAUSE]
Aoife, there is someone who can do this. And
that is the amazing Lucy Haken who
is my producer, who tells me she can, which
is why we're here. So ladies and gentleman,
Lucy Haken.
[APPLAUSE]
I would protect your ears, here, not because
Lucy is terrible at singing, but because it's
just very, very loud. OK, let's have a go.
Hoo. Hoo.
Oh!
[APPLAUSE]
Aoife, she broke the glass. But you're a much
better singer. Thank you so much.